RIGHT NOW I WANT TO BRING IN THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE MARICOPA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, BILL
GATES, MR. GAETZ, THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US, AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW THE REPUBLICAN
GUNNER IN ATORIAL CANDIDATE KARI
LAKE IS ACCUSING YOU AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS OF
INTENTIONALLY, INTENTIONALLY
MISLEADING, AND GOING AHEAD AND
BLOWING THIS -- ROLLING THIS
PROCESS FORWARD, AND SHE'S
WORRIED ABOUT THE INTEGRITY OF
WHAT'S GOING ON.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO WHAT SHE
SAID.
>> THEY'RE DRAGGING THEIR FEET,
AND THEY'RE SLOW ROLLING THE
RESULTS, AND THEY'RE TRYING TO
DELAY THE INEVITABLE.
THIS IS JUST AN EMBARRASSMENT,
AND THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA ARE
SICK AND TIRED OF ELECTIONS
BEING RUN LIKE WE'RE IN SOME
BANANA REPUBLIC.
I HAVE VERY LITTLE FAITH IN SOME
OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE OPERATING
THAT MARICOPA COUNTY ELECTIONS.
I THINK THEY'RE INCOMPETENT.
>> MR. GATES, I WANT YOUR
REACTION TO WHAT WE JUST HEARD.
>> WELL, WOLF, THANKS FOR HAVING
ME.
AND IT'S REALLY SAD TO HEAR THAT
WE HAVE THE REPUBLICAN NOMINEE
OF GOVERNOR, FOR GOVERNOR HERE
IN ARIZONA, WHO'S TALKING LIKE
THAT.
I THINK THE VOTES THAT WERE JUST
RELEASED, 78,000, THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN MAGICALLY.
IT HAPPENS BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE
BEHIND ME, ALL THE PEOPLE HERE
IN MARICOPA COUNTY ELECTIONS,
WHO ARE WORKING SO HARD.
THEY'RE WORKING 14 TO 18 HOUR
DAYS EVERY DAY.
WE'RE ABOUT TO GO INTO A HOLIDAY
WEEKEND WITH VETERANS DAY, AND
THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK THOSE KIND OF HOURS ON THE
HOLIDAY, FRIDAY, ON SATURDAY,
AND SUNDAY.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT KARI LAKE
WANTS US TO MOVE QUICKLY, AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE DO.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT, IS THAT THIS IS DONE
ACCURATELY.
THAT IS THE FOCUS.
AND THAT, YOU KNOW, LIKE FOR ALL
OF THESE MAIL-IN BALLOTS, THAT
THOSE ARE SIGNATURE VERIFIED.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME AS
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL, THAT ONLY
ELIGIBLE PEOPLE, ONLY ELIGIBLE
VOTES ARE COUNT.
I WOULD THINK THAT KARI LAKE
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN THAT AS
WELL.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I RAN ON,
ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
I SUPPORT ID AT THE POLLS AND
ALL THOSE THINGS, THEY MIGHT
TAKE A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME BUT
IT ENSURES THAT ONLY THOSE
ELIGIBLE PEOPLE ARE VOTING.
>> MR. GATES, IT'S JOHN KING.
I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME, I KNOW
YOU'RE INCREDIBLY BUSY.
I'VE BEEN TO YOUR OFFICE,
OFFICES LIKE YOURS ALL AROUND
THE COUNTRY, AND THESE ARE
HONEST HARD WORKING PEOPLE WHO
DON'T GET PAID ENOUGH MONEY
DOING THE WORK OF DEMOCRACY.
BUT TO KARI LAKE'S POINT, I WANT
YOU TO EXPLAIN.
NUMBER ONE, YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN.
I WANT OUR VIEWERS TO KNOW THAT.
THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR IS QUESTIONING AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL, WHEN SHE SAYS
THAT ON TELEVISION.
WHEN I ASKED YOUR CALL ON PIMA
COUNTY EARLIER, IN THAT ROOM
BEHIND YOU KARI LAKE HAS
REPRESENTATIVES WHO HAVE EYES ON
EVERYTHING THAT IS HAPPENING,
CORRECT, SO IF SHE HAD ANY -- IF
THEY SAW ANYTHING SPECIFIC THAT
THEY COULD RAISE QUESTIONS
ABOUT, SHE WOULD BE ABLE TO SAY
I SAW X AS OPPOSED TO I ACCUSE
THEM OF THINGS WITH ABSENTEE
INFORMATION.
SORRY TO ASK A LONG QUESTION.
THERE ARE DEMOCRATIC AND
CAMPAIGN REPRESENTATIVES BEHIND
THAT GLASS BEHIND YOU WHO ARE
WATCHING EVERYTHING THAT'S
HAPPENING?
>> SO, I DON'T KNOW, THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION, AND YOU'RE
RIGHT, THERE ARE REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATIC EYES ON EVERYTHING
THROUGH THE PROCESS, AND I
ACTUALLY KNOW THIS FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE BEFORE I WAS
ELECTED TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I ACTUALLY USED TO
BE A REPUBLICAN LAWYER WHO WOULD
COME DOWN HERE AND OBSERVE THIS,
BACK IN THE 2006 RACE IT WAS A
CLOSE CONGRESSIONAL RACE BETWEEN
JD HAYWORTH AND HARRY MITCHELL,
I WAS DOWN HERE FOR DAYS AFTER
ELECTION DAY.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO THE
PROCESS.
WE COULD NOT DO WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE TODAY AND HAVE BEEN DOING
FOR THE PAST FEW DAYS IF WE'RE
NOT FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE EYEBALLS ON
EVERYTHING.
>> YEAH, EXCELLENT, EXCELLENT
POINT.
CHAIRMAN GATES, WHEN WILL WE SEE
THE FIRST OF THE, WHAT, 290,000
SAME DAY DROPOFF BALLOTS?
>> YES, WE SHOULD START TO SEE
THOSE TOMORROW, I BELIEVE, WE'LL
START SEEING THOSE COME IN,
AGAIN, THAT 290,000 MAIL-IN
BALLOTS THAT WERE DROPPED OFF ON
ELECTION DAY ON TUESDAY, THAT'S
THE MOST EVER WE'VE HAD ON
ELECTION DAY.
AND, IN FACT, IT BROKE THE
PREVIOUS RECORD BY 70 #%.
SO IT'S A LOT OF BALLOTS THAT
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO PROCESS
BEHIND ME.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO GET THROUGH
IT.
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT ON A
TIMELINE, WHICH IS FRANKLY
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT IT TAKES,
HOW LONG IT TAKES US TO GET THIS
DONE.
EVERY TWO, AND EVERY FOUR YEARS.
SO THERE'S NOTHING OUT OF THE
ORDINARY, IT MAKES ME WONDER IF
KARI LAKE HAS REALLY BEEN
FOLLOWING ELECTIONS IN THE PAST
IN MARICOPA COUNTY.
>> WELL, CHAIRMAN GATES TO
CLARIFY WILL WE SEE THE FIRST OF
THOSE RESULTS AS EARLY AS
TOMORROW?
>> YES.
>> ANY IDEA WHAT TIME?
>> I THINK -- I WOULD EXPECT,
AGAIN, IN THE EVENING.
I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT TIME, BUT
TOMORROW EVENING WE SHOULD SEE
THE NEXT RELEASE OF VOTES.
>> AND WE'LL OF COURSE BE WITH
YOU TOMORROW NIGHT, WE'LL BE
WATCHING ALL OF THIS UNFOLD, AS
THE STAKES ARE SO ENORMOUS,
RIGHT NOW.
ONCE AGAIN, I WANT TO ECHO WHAT
JOHN TOLD YOU, CHAIRMAN GATES,
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO YOU, ALL THE
WORKERS WHO ARE WORKING AROUND
THE CLOCK, TO GET THE JOB DONE.
THIS IS DEMOCRACY, IN ACTION,
RIGHT NOW, AND WE APPRECIATE IT.
VERY, VERY MUCH.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US, I
ASSUME WE'LL CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION TOMORROW.
APPRECIATE IT.